[Music]
this is star talk i'm neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist got
chuck nice with me chuck baby hey neil
what's happening
all right all right today's gonna be
cosmic queries and you know what the
subject is going to be oh my this is a
good subject okay
it's your your brain on movies your
brain on movies
okay now i remember the commercials
where my brain was in a skillet
oh i remember that one your brain on
drugs and this is your brain on
breakfast
chuck how old are you uh yeah
that commercial was 1971 or oh no way
no way that i think that was the 90s man
yeah they took a fried egg and dropped
it into a very hot skillet and that was
your brain on drugs and every time i saw
it i was like and now i'm hungry
now i'm just hungry i just want
breakfast now well this is a brain
episode and we don't do brain things
without our uh
brain brainiac at large heather berlin
heather welcome back to star talk hey
how are you guys doing thanks for having
me all right excellent excellent
that's gonna be my new subheading brain
brainiac yeah and so you're a
neuroscientist at the icon school of
medicine at mount sinai and right here
in new york city so it's great to have
you back for the for the gazillionth
time we love the brain as a subject and
especially since i don't have any
expertise i get to learn something for
every one of these episodes that's part
of part of why
we love you as a guest because i i get
to learn
and so but first let me let me start off
with some questions um there are a
subset of movies
that
uh that specialize in
unusual things going on in people's
brains
right and some of them are just really
smart people all right and
they become the subject of it but
there's also what's going on in the
brain of the person watching the movie
and
it seems to be more than just
entertainment sometimes
extra changes are going on in people's
heads and one of the biggest ones that
people always ask about is do violent
movies make you violent do they
desensitize you or do can you
distinguish
between fiction
violence and actual violence and if you
do then what's everybody complaining
about and if you can't why hasn't all of
that been outlawed you know 100 years
ago
good question
there's actually there have been some
some neuroimaging studies which look at
what happens in people's brains when
they're looking when they're watching
violent videos let's say a riot or
somebody getting beating up and they
compare it to when they're viewing a
natural scene
and what they find is actually when
they're viewing violence images they get
decreased activation of parts of their
prefrontal cortex if it was the scene of
an actual riot or one that was you know
created with um actors
uh most of the time it won't make a
difference in terms of that decreased
activation in the prefrontal cortex
because the more engrossed you are in a
film and there are other measures that
can look that level of engrossment the
more you perceive that as as your
reality and so it can decrease your
prefrontal cortex activation and in turn
you might be more prone toward either
impulsive or violent behavior for a
short period of time after you've
watched that film
so now what happens if you're looking at
the nature scene
and um
you you just feel like uh killing
flowers
then what
what's that mean
or trouncing on the grasses right you
just you just want to stomp dandelions
you know what i mean well i think we
have we have a different sense of
killing plants than we do of killing
animals for sure but here's what's
really interesting i mean there are
measures so there's something i mean
there's a whole field now called
neurocinematics which is basically the
study of what your brain looks like when
you know you're watching film
and one of the big measures they look at
is something called inter-subject
correlation so it's not what areas of
brain are active in your particular
brain per se when you're watching a film
but they'll look across many subjects
all watching the same film and the level
at which their brain activation syncs up
is a measure of how engrossing that film
is how much it's able to capture your
attention and films vary in their
ability to do this so for example the
highest inter-subject correlation in
this study was alfred hitchcock film so
he was a master at
using cinematography and all the sound
and light to grab people's attention and
draw them in and play them like it like
a violin whereas other films um less so
like compared to a larry david episode
for example which is more sort of
there was an analysis just right into
playing exactly what you said heather i
watched an analysis of a hitchcock film
forgive me i don't remember which but
is walking down the stairs of this home
with a glass of milk
which has poison in it and they're going
to feed the glass of milk to the person
and kill them
and
your eye goes straight to the milk and i
don't learn until this is analyzed by
the by the you know the reviewers that
alfred hitchcock put a light bulb inside
the glass of milk which gave it a kind
of a glow but you just see it as white
it's milk is white so it's just white
but it caught your attention and you're
not even thinking that it's glowing
you're just thinking it's milk but so he
was really right in there to do this
interesting now about and also he was
very good at um creating uh the tension
necessary to grab
your gaze
so
in psycho
you never saw her get stabbed it just
didn't happen
you know for all you knew uh she had a
bloody nose
because you never saw a knife go into
her you know and then i forget the other
one where there's a bomb under the table
and the whole idea is you know there's a
bomb under the table but the people
don't know there's a bomb under the
table so
you're now feeling the anxiety
as if you were
sitting at the table but you can't tell
these people there's a bomb there like
get up get out you know so
but here's the thing it's that suspense
is what draws people because once these
sort of surprise happens or you know the
the guy jumps out from behind the closet
it's kind of it's over then you just
have this full like fear response but
the build up that's your feargasm that
was your feargasm okay for those who
love it okay it's all over there the
builds up that's the real you know that
that's what draws you in isn't that
always hyper vigilance what's going to
happen when is it going to happen where
should i look and they also have done
eye tracking studies so on certain films
you know you you look across many
subjects and they're all concentrated at
looking at the same places on the screen
but when you have them they compared it
to for example looking at a natural
scene in like washington square park
just natural footage and people are
looking in all other directions but just
because eye gaze is at a certain place
doesn't mean that the brains are synced
up so you have to look at both behavior
which is eye gaze and
brain activation because there's parts
of the brain that have to do with
self-referential so they do it for
commercials too and they and they find
that they they want to create they'll
test different videos the ones that
activate the amygdala which is the kind
of emotional center of the brain and
these parts of the prefrontal cortex
that have to do with um your personal
story that are self-referential so the
more that the images or the story can
you can reflect and refer to something
in your own history
the more um emotionally and more
attached you'll be to it so these are
the kinds of ways they're trying to
structure for example commercials and
also film you know film is more
engrossing
okay
wait one second here
isn't is it doesn't there have to be
a a diminishing return on that like the
more you manipulate me
the less i'm able to be manipulated
because
like you're
toying with my emotions kind of
and so i'm not going to keep giving you
that same emotional response
why not because why not okay think of it
this way
when you go to the puppy store you're
like oh my god these puppies puppies
right but but if you but if you work at
the puppy store
you get these smelly puppies out of here
right now you're like empties puppies
crapping off crapping all over
stank ass puppies all over the place i
can't stand puppies you know what i like
i like dogs because they get the hell
out of my store
um here's the thing here's the thing
it's not like a steady stream of
emotional manipulation so if you think
of for example even a hitchcock movie or
any suspense movie it's not suspense the
whole time then your brain would
habituate and it would get boring it's
build up build up surprise and then like
mundane mundane and then another
suspenseful moment so with commercials
they can vary you know it's not that the
whole time you're being emotionally
manipulated it might just be
at the end or you know
interspersed with other things so as
long as you can vary it right and change
it up a bit you'll keep being activated
by the by the emotions like but if you
were to see you know those animal rescue
commercials which kill me with the
animals and the cages but if you want to
see one commercial like that after the
other after the other after the other
eventually i'm sarah mclaughlin
won't you please help
these animals need you so much
[Laughter]
yes yeah so we can anyway the point is
as we're using neuroimaging um
to help filmmakers we're also you know
it's also being used in in the
advertising industry as well um to
create more engrossing commercials uh so
it's where science meets you know the
arts in another
way now you you you throw this term
around very glibly and i just want to
make sure we're on the same page when
you say prefrontal cortex
is this larger in humans than in other
mammals
nice
well okay so it's relative so the
relative size of the prefrontal cortex
compared to the rest of the brain
um
humans have the largest prefrontal
cortex compared to the rest of the brain
than other animals but if you think of
it like a whale objectively it has a
larger prefrontal cortex than a human
right right but the ratio so compared to
the rest of the brain we have the
largest prefrontal cortex compared to
and the prefrontal cortex does what for
us specifically right so it's my
favorite part of the brain because it's
involved in so many things one of which
is impulse control how to both regulate
our emotions control our impulses um
decision making organization we call it
it's the executive function it's the
executor of the brain so it enables
civilization to exist
if you think about it basically yes i've
often said that without the prefrontal
cortex there would be no civilization
because we couldn't
um cr you know organize and create we
would just be busy having our immediate
rewards and not thinking about building
or creating a future or anything like
that right well there are other animals
that have societies as well do they have
developed prefrontal cortexes i mean
other other great apes actually have
hierarchies they have social constructs
they have means of communication
they have tasks that they all uh kind of
allocate to one another and positions
but chuck they don't have trains planes
and automobiles and you know and and
skyscrapers and wouldn't be funny if
they if they actually thought of that
and said you know what one day that's
going to lead us to a place where we
destroy ourselves and the plan
there's something really cool there's
something called the dunbar number so
it's because it's created by someone a
researcher named dunbar but basically oh
i thought it was created by somebody
named number but
yeah that's good chuck right
oh okay okay i'm sorry heather yeah you
had to you walked into that one that was
one that
dunbar number created by somebody named
number
okay
um
so there there is a direct correlation
between relative size of the prefrontal
cortex to the rest of the brain and the
the
scale of the society
so you can tell
how many yeah so so the larger the
societies of you know that worked the
larger the prefrontal cortex humans have
the largest and as you go down with the
great apes and and other species the
sizes of their society directly
correlate to the size of their
prefrontal cortex so there's definitely
something about you know social
interactions but there's also thinking
about the future being able to plan for
the future and so yeah without our
prefrontal cortex there would be no
society there so so there are no there
are no shrimp sitting around going i
wonder if there is indeed a night sky
huh
why why
why am i so lonely where are the other
shrimp how come no one ever talks to me
and why am i here what is my mission
yes
what is my purpose what is the message
right so
so that means almost everything you've
described in the prefrontal cortex is an
interaction point in a movie that you
sit down and watch
well that's interesting no no i say that
because it you can't really show a movie
to a dog right they're not they're not
interested even though they're
recognizable
they're recognizable people they're
recognizable scenes they're but they're
not they're not going to interact
mentally the way we are because it's a
mental thing to get meaning out of it
they're not going to extract meaning i
mean you can show an animal a dog as a
video of other dogs and it will be you
know it'll grab its attention and it'll
it'll be attracted to it it will watch
it even but to then extrapolate meaning
or how is this reference to me you know
self-referential um they're not other
species i mean i met a dog once that
jumped up and barked any time i saw a
dog on the tv and that was hilarious
yeah yeah because the dog i grew up with
it's real
didn't care about the tv it's also a
dumb dog
yeah the dog i had was pretty smart
growing up right so she did not bark it
didn't stare at herself in the mirror
you know it was like all right so so
heather tell me about
thanks for that that you know prefrontal
cortex 101. um but i still thought the
hippocampus was something something
important but apparently not
yeah it's just it just has to do with
all your memories it just that's all
just everything that you are just the
collection of all that you are that's
all that is
you know
all those things that if they go away
you have no idea who you are or what
you're here for oh it's just that
okay so heather we know chuck and i know
that you are
you're a mind reader okay you you attach
electrodes to whoever walks within 10
feet of you and then you study this so
it's one thing to just say there's
there's activation in one part of the
brain or the other we get that
but what's this i hear that recently you
can actually reconstruct
the thoughts
rather than just say where the thought
is happening that's a whole other level
of getting inside somebody's head wow
yeah yeah i mean so so we're at the
early stages now and it started with
just images right
so so basically you would you would feed
you would have someone in a scanner you
would show them a picture say of a you
know a shoe or a cat and you would get
this pattern of activation based on
these like voxels like the little pixels
that that you can read as an image but
just to be clear a voxel is a
three-dimensional pixel
isn't that correct yes i'm pretty sure
yeah okay mm-hmm
is it yes yes yes so so based on this
sort of let's just say you know this
this data of what the brain is doing
when it's seeing a particular image
um then you can um show a person a
different image
and the give that information to the
computer and based on on on feeding it
many many other images that you know a
person might see
it can predict
what image you're looking at
so it can or interpret it in your brain
activation it can interpret i would say
identical appropriate identifying
the image you're looking at based on the
feedback that it's receiving from you
after you will give all the information
to it it then looks at you
and determines what you're looking at
okay yeah with shapes and everything it
shakes you know it makes it expects its
best guess at what you're looking at
basically how accurate though
you say early stages but how how well is
it performing a high degree of accuracy
oh it's a high degree of accuracy i want
to give you a number but i don't have a
number offhand but very highly you got
you guys always you just you're never
satisfied are you right you're just
you're never satisfied i mean first come
up with artificial intelligence now now
you're gonna let machines be able to
read our minds okay i mean
and then on top of that okay let me just
say this uh i feel sorry for your
husband um i know him very well
okay he's married to a woman who says
what are you thinking and he goes
nothing and she's like no i'm gonna find
out what the hell
speaking of which
speaking of which actually so there's
been studies that have done that this
was a paper that was published in
science um where they woke up people at
different stages of sleep but stage one
two
early sleep and
they would say what were you um they're
in the scanner so they were imaging
their brain at the time and they would
ask them to report what they were seeing
what they were dreaming about
and again the the computer algorithm
could protect predict with very high
accuracy for example that they they the
computer would spit out let's say an
image of a person or a key or a chair
and the person would say um you know i
was having the stream about this person
and there was like a key on the chair or
whatever it would correlate
with what the oh my god algorithm
right so now you can start to read
streams and they do and they've done it
now with images so they've had people
watching films
and and the and the the the computer
basically constructs a video based on
what it thinks you're seeing based on
your brain activation which really it's
amazing you can go online and see this
these images that really look like the
actual film they're seeing it's fuzzy
and it's not you know it's not a clear
image but it's a fuzzy like moving
object that's moving in a similar
pattern as to what the person is seeing
so again i say early stages because it's
not this exact um it's it's very fuzzy
but as time goes on it's going to get
clearer and clearer could you could you
identify that monster that was always
chasing me as a kid in my dreams
i'll have to send it to the algorithm
the algorithm the algorithm is now
freddie cruz algorithm
freddy krueger algorithm that's what
we're going to send it to yeah i mean
what's going to be really cool honestly
that you mentioned that neil is that
ultimately we can combine that with
other techniques that we're using to
like kind of zap out um fearful memories
and they're
with neural implants or soften them at
least yeah implants yeah you can then
see oh this person's having a type of
brain activation which suggests it's a
scary monster coming into the dream and
then do a little you know zap and just
you know change the scene yeah all of my
images would basically come back uh not
as visuals but as um
a wawa guitar going wow
wow so
plus you have to be careful because if
you
if you zap the part where it's a monster
chasing you it could turn it into like a
like a a bunny rabbit chasing you and
now you're scared of bunny rabbits
suddenly you wake up and you're totally
afraid of them right yeah once you start
messing around with the hardware you
never know what's gonna happen that's
true you need to be careful we're
getting to the point where it's going to
be something like you know minority
report perhaps you know not that you
could predict the future but that you
can kind of
read people's brain activity and see
what they were thinking at a particular
time
and if you're if you can record that
information you know you can see whether
a person might have committed a crime or
so forth so i mean it can be used in all
sorts of ways so it's
the minor report one of the great brain
movies when you think about it that way
i love that and of course half the
episodes of the netflix series
black mirror
involved the brain yes behaving just
like a a disc of data yes that you can
upload and download and alter and and so
so yeah it was and if if heather
continues as she is
she
will be
the black mirror yeah
she will be
we'll take a quick break we'll take a
quick break when we come this is a
cosmic aquarius when we come back we're
going to pick up questions from our uh
loyal patreon members and chuck has them
all lined up when star talk continues
we're back star talk your brain on
movies
with heather bernaland and of course i
got chuck nice here uh heather how do we
find you on social media
heather underscore berlin on twitter and
instagram don't forget the underscore
which i know you love neil
no no underscore is like the
lamest thing that could ever be in a
handle but we'll we'll we'll accept it
uh before we go to questions let me ask
a quick
um i'm i am
while i find them entertaining
there's an absence of plausibility that
concerns me anytime
it's one of these movies where someone
gets really really really smart
and
those people in every one of these
movies do things like move objects with
their brain power
and it's like no
if you're smarter you'll just solve
problems faster or better you're not
going to all of a sudden start moving
stuff so so where did this come from why
do people think your brain could ever
possibly have that power other than just
i'm really smart so i can solve
something you can't
yeah i think it's all predicated on this
myth that we only use 10 of our brain
and like imagine we can use all of our
brain and the powers we would have but
the entire premise of the movie lucy the
entire premise of that film or limitless
is another one um you know just take
this pill and then you can idiot
you use all of your faith
um you use all your brain and none of it
is redundant it uses so many resources
um energy blood flow it it we don't
waste those resources in our body just
thinking about evolution but
um most of it is just happening outside
of awareness we're unconscious about
what's happening and sometimes we can
when we think about meditation and other
techniques of mindfulness we can bring
more of what's happening unconsciously
to our conscious attention
but it's not that we're using more of
our brain and i think with the like
being able to move things or telepathy i
mean this is just wishful thinking on
the part of people i mean i remember
laying in the bed with my daughter and i
did not want to get up she said please
mommy get that book on the shelf and i
said let me just let's both try really
hard and just will it over here so we
don't have to go
it just
it didn't work
and if you and if it had worked you'd
have been like all right sweetie and now
you have to move out of the house
no rename her tabitha yeah
you can't live here anymore matilda yeah
either
okay so chuck give me some questions
from our fan base here we go let's uh
pop it off with bridge bridge
karen or charon says
have we gained any insight into the
long-term effects of the brain uh
long-term effects the brain gets from
misinformation pop culture specifically
during the pandemic i think
more pointedly
what are the effects
of exposure to misinformation whether
you live in a misinformation bubble
or if you're just encountering
misinformation that is counter to what
uh you already believe what because
that's what that's what's happening now
and let me
dovetail that can you ever emerge out of
it right
yes
how do we save these poor sap so we're
being duped all the time
well you know there's there's a way of
seeing the world and interacting with
the world that i think you know as
scientists learn early on and it's just
sort of like question everything you
know be skeptical look for evidence um
but when you're in these echo chambers
and these bubbles and especially when
they're they're on issues where they are
emotionally significant
um people tend to
disconfirm
what doesn't go along with their beliefs
in terms of the evidence and and only
pay attention to things that support
what they already believe in so the
so it's very difficult to break this um
bias it's a cognitive bias
but what you
the best way is that you have to meet a
person where they're at so say oh i hear
you that you believe i don't know for
example that there's no such thing as
you know
climate gravity shame
gravity whatever the earth is flat earth
right right i hear you that you believe
that and i understand and then sort of
maybe even cite something that their
evidence for that that they and then say
that's really interesting but have you
ever thought about this other thing
there's also this other evidence that
suggests this you have to as soon as you
come in
in an aggressive controversial way
they're going to shut it out immediately
but if you meet people where they're at
empathize with their emotions and okay i
hear you you don't want to take vaccines
i know you're scared you know but let's
talk about it and find a way in then
maybe they'll be more open to hearing an
alternative view the way that people are
doing it now isn't working it's just
like my side or you're crazy and that
that's never gonna work you know why
because it's my side or you're crazy
that's why it says that's why that's why
[Laughter]
wait wait so heather this is a serious
flaw in the human mind
yes is there any understanding of its
origins
evolutionarily or otherwise
are are bi well there there's something
called
so with group affiliation right yes you
were safer when you were in groups right
and so there's also the higher the sort
of um entrance fee to get into the group
the greater the group affiliation so if
you think about like sororities and
fraternities how they have all these
crazy things you have to do to get in so
once you're in
yeah you have protection of the group
whatever but the psychology is that
you've gone through so much to get into
this group
you're more likely to be persuaded by
their belief system and to want to keep
that group affiliation because there are
some evolutionary gains from that
there's protection there's you know
better survival in a group so some of
those group dynamics are also at play
here
okay so it basically it's it's miss
we still have these tendencies at a time
in a place where we no longer need them
and so
we are suffering from our own
evolutionary past so true yeah i know
and also we're living in a in this
technology world now that our brains
have not evolved quickly enough to to
accommodate right yeah so our we have
these old caveman brains that are
working you know in this modern
technology with information being being
bombarded by this information
um and and we're not able to process it
and really analyze it in a way that's
that's gonna be to our advantage so i
think this is part of the problem yeah
also the uh what you just said is
you know what exacerbates the problem is
we can find those groups and that safety
because of the technology where
otherwise we would have been ostracized
and marginalized and isolated because we
felt that you know uh i don't know
eating children was a good thing right
but then we go online and we find like
other people who say you know children
are delicious why shouldn't we eat them
and then all of a sudden i i i feel like
oh i'm i'm okay i'm all right
chuck is that the best example you could
have given
it is
of all the examples you could have given
i'm just saying i uh you know i read
hansel and gretel to my daughter the
other day and uh
it got me wondering every one of those
stories somebody a chilled child dances
in every one of those stories i'm sorry
at one point eating kids was a thing
because guess what
all of these stories a whole lot of
those stories end up with somebody gotta
eat a kid
peter and the wolf
eating the kids
chuck is on to something i'm pretty sure
eating a kid had to be a thing at some
point
at some point in society we said you
know what man we got to stop eating
these kids
this is out of control guys
we can no longer mask it in our
allegories and our children's horror
stories we just have to stop eating kids
all right
all right okay
i'm sorry
all right back to back to back to base
okay
chuck gotti give me another question all
right here we go
this is katherine
uh
gallerini
more
says this hello doctors
and chuck uh
she missed your lord episode so that's
all right exactly
uh as augmented reality and virtual
reality
movies and gaming experiences become
more mainstream are we learning through
scientific studies as
as to whether or not the brain processes
ar vr stories differently
or the same
as if we're watching a flat screen
if so what are the differences or if
you're watching just reality right i
mean just put that on there on the list
too right
it's
so really the differences are the level
of engrossment so the brain it's dark in
there it's black it doesn't actually see
anything right and so all it is is
getting stimuli coming in as ones and
zeros you know from the retina let's say
visual stimuli and it's interpreting
that information so whether it's real
life
whether it's you know on a flat screen
whether it's virtual reality it's if
you're fully attending to that
information
um and and not having there's always
another little part of green saying oh
you're watching a movie or this isn't
real but once you kind of you know
that's when they say you know you go to
a film and you um what do they call it
when you
suspend your disbelief right so once
you're in the mode of suspending your
disbelief
it all is the same and virtual reality
is just much more engrossing
but you can be as
engrossed in a virtual reality as you
are when you're watching a film on a big
screen it doesn't make a huge difference
other than how
what is your ability to suspend your
disbelief and so that's the thing you're
playing with the more it becomes
more engrossed you are the easier it is
to forget that you're you know this is a
simulation
so just just for just to put this on the
table
um i'm old enough to remember shari
lewis and her hand puppet
lamb chop
at no time did i think lamb chop was
real
i could not suspend my disbelief looking
at a talking sock
that was never worked for me at any age
no i wasn't even gonna try it's like no
i'm not doing this
okay but how about this did you watch
sesame street well maybe i don't know
i'm too old for sesame street
my sister watched it yeah
you know but okay so what about sesame
street
you know when you're watching sesame
street weren't you not feeling that
maybe oscar was a real character or big
bird was a kermit the frog or were you
thinking oh that's just a puppet there's
some guy's hand controlling it okay when
i got older i got better at that and in
fact uh was it kermit i was on stage
once
kermit the frog i think i met kermit the
frog on stage and while there i totally
blocked out the fact that there's a
human being there with his hand and a
stick right and and i was having it was
just me and kermit and i think we we we
were doing good it was god i want to
meet kermit the prague
just so i can say you think it's a
heartbeat and green really
it ain't easy being green okay yeah the
same thing is happening
stop being black
there you go you got it you got it
really quick
chuck it was allegory chuck you know it
was alligator
okay
um
the same thing is happening with these
robots these companions that they're
creating now right so you know that
you're interacting with like they're
your pet or they're becoming you know
we're anthropomorphizing these these
robots so the closer they can act and
look and sound and facial expressions
like a human
you're going to forget that it's a robot
and interact with it in that way so it's
the same thing whether you're watching a
film interacting with an ai
the the the more realistic it is the
easier it is for you to forget that it's
not reality now how much of that has to
do with the your association
from an early age
like i don't care
how realistic you make a robot pet for
me to i'm just it's never going to be a
pet it's going to be a robot to me but i
have a feeling that if you gave my
eight-year-old daughter a robot pet
anything dog cat whatever as she got
older and became more uh how can i say
familiar with that as a as an actual
thing when she you know when it would
just be nothing to have a robot pet
well i i think it's just a matter of
what can fool you i'm sure when you were
a kid whatever
thing i know they had like a teddy
ruxpin or whatever they had then at that
point maybe was able to fool you i
remember teddy ruxpin and i hated it but
go ahead no no chuck i think i think
you're asking something different i
think it's
it's one thing to say i have this robot
pet and i'm perfectly happy with it it's
another thing to have a robot pet and
you think it's no longer a robot right
so i think your daughter is not going to
think the robot is ever real but she'll
be perfectly content with a robot pet
just as an evolution of pets i have a
robot pet so it really isn't about your
belief that it's your i don't think it
has to be it's your belief that it's a
pet not that it's yes that's real
or correct yeah or that it's you know
it's a real robot
just like a real mouse or a real hamster
the real question that the deeper
question i think is whether this thing
has consciousness or not and so when we
start talking to like the alexa i mean
we start my kids talk to the alexa like
it's a person that has a conscious there
was a movie about that yes yes yeah and
they asked her questions oh well she'll
know like she she knows everything and
no and it's very hard to explain to a
child well this this is not this is just
a
an
algorithm not an actual
conscious person but yeah but they get
confused and so it has to do with
earlier stages of development but why
does it matter what why does it matter
it matters
that's a philosophical question really
why does it matter
if i can't tell the difference then who
cares alex is my friend
because okay tell me why after the break
then
see what i did there
suspense i'm trying to do a hitchcock
thing here uh when we come back we're
gonna find out does it matter if you
know in advance something is real or
fake if it serves your needs and if it
makes you happy then what do you care if
it's a robot or a human being when we
come back star talk your brain on movies
we're back star talk third and final
segment of your brain on movies we're
doing cosmic queries here and we left
off with a thought i basically i was
challenging heather with the thought
that
uh if if your kids
have alexa and they think alexa's real
but even if they don't think alexa is
real alexa knows more than any other
human
so
why does it matter to you
whether they think alexa is real or not
what difference does it make
this is their friend on the other
side of a box
here's the differentiation i think that
it matters
um because well it matters if it's real
or not because it it's how we treat it
so for example if your you know
refrigerator is not conscious um it's
okay if you kick it or smash it or
unplug it for alexa for example but if
it really if you think it really has
feelings
and then you do things to it that you
know smash it
shut it down you know that that has
ethical
there are more ethical considerations to
that so how you treat the thing
it matters
so i mean this is a case in which you
know what does it matter whether a child
believes it's conscious or not well yeah
because if it believes it's conscious
and then it you know says i hate you
alexa and it starts smashing it
it's a different scenario
you're next yeah you know then you know
you have a psychopath on your hands
right right mm-hmm so so how we treat
these objects whether they're conscious
or whether they actually are have
subjective experience or not matters but
it also matters in what we believe
because that tells us about that that
person if a person is is negative to
something they believe is conscious then
we have to say this person might have
some psychopathic tendencies so there
are some reasons good answer good answer
yeah yeah yeah all right chuck keep it
going this is our last segment alexa
you're safe for another day
this is alejandro reynoso
from monterrey mexico
[Laughter]
of mental illness in a movie or a series
and by that i mean the closest to
reality
okay so heather what do you have there
so i mean there's so many films that i
think do it right um well one of the
just one of the caveats is that
when it's not done right they show
mental illnesses just being this like
stable thing this trait once you have it
you're this person but a lot of the time
mental illness
the severity can ebb and flow throughout
a lifetime so you might have ocd might
have a really bad episode then you get
better for a while and then it's bad
again so so some of the films that do it
well um certainly a beautiful mind um
portrayal john nash because it the films
where they allow you to actually get
inside the head of somebody who's
experiencing mental illness to feel what
it might feel like um birdman that was
with michael keaton
um which was another one where they take
you into his mind and you're almost
there with them and see what this might
experience what it might feel like to
have hallucinations and delusions and
how you can easily slip from reality
into these these these delusions
and was it the grandfather the recent
film that came out during covet
yeah with alzheimer's with alzheimer's
and i think it's twist on a typical
story
was that
the
he sees is it his wife someone comes in
twice
but he doesn't recognize her as his wife
but it's played by a completely
different actress
um
you are now in this man's head yeah you
are it's who are you i don't get out of
here i don't know who you are that's
right wow
the other memento was a film from a
while back about memory memory issues
and you're trying to experience it the
way he's experiencing it you don't know
what's happening either you're kind of
lost and it's not a real cause it's not
a real condition by the way that that
where you just you you have but you do
have long-term memory but you have zero
short-term memory right
it's called like a dissociative fugue
it's when you you go into these few
states where you you just forget
completely who you are and and where
you're from and um yeah so that is that
so those some of those films which drag
you in pie which was another one that
was a darren aronofsky film um from a
while back um so those films that bring
you in um even the shining you know you
mean the life of pie the light no no no
there was a
film i think it was in the 1990s called
pi
pi okay okay yeah yeah yeah and it was a
different
uh apple pie and then there was another
sequel
yeah i don't think that i don't think
those are real sequels
i never heard a pie but
there's so many so those films that
really bring you in um but other ones
you know that like dissociative identity
disorder or split personality disorder
black swan natalie portman i think she
got an oscar for that's for playing that
role um where she was actually her it
was two actresses it was her and um
i forgot the name of the other actress
she's she's married to ashton kutcher
miller mila kriller milo kunis mila
he played this other character the whole
time you think it's two different
characters or fight club same thing you
think it's two different characters but
you're really it's this one you know
brad pitt i do have to give a shout out
to one of my but i always cite in my
classes for an example of borderline
personality disorder is glenn close and
fatal attraction it's a movie from the
80s
it's such a it's
an extreme portrayal but of a borderline
personality disorder also girl
interrupted is another good one there's
so many so many oh i know girl
interrupted that one was good
yeah that had an early angelina jolie
was in that but not as the star she was
a side a side character and are you are
you sure
did you get your two movies right
i thought fatal attraction had the other
woman in it there were two similar
movies
are you sure about that okay then
there's another movie uh with
um what's her name which she crosses her
legs in front of the interview camera oh
sharon stone sharon stone that was
another one of those instinct basic
instinct weren't there like the same
movie basically
different they were different
that was polite of you there
it's the same but different right okay
i mean yeah
um silver linings playbook is a more
recent one that was portraying on
bipolar uh it was with bradley cooper
and
the uh
uh katniss katniss everdeen it was
bradley cooper and katniss everdeen yes
that is everdeen yeah whatever her
reasoning is jennifer's name
jennifer lawrence
thank you
yeah
so which one of these are the best would
you say
the the best what portrayal of mental
health yeah yeah would you say
do you want me to pick one um um
uh
that's too difficult um i'll pick one
i'll pick one i just read flowers for
algernon and i went out and saw the
movie charlie with cliff robertson and i
was very moved by that
where he's they he's um mentally
disabled and they have a test
serum that they give him where he
becomes really smart and you slowly
watch him get smarter and smarter and
smarter and then he gets smarter than
all of the friends who used to make fun
of him for how non-smart he was and then
they no longer want to be his friend
and then the serum wears off and then he
goes back to the way he was oh my gosh
and it was
very and he wanted academy award for
that i'm pretty sure wow
yeah charlie it's basically based on the
flowers for algernon story okay
huh i'll tell you one really good one
that's that portrays addiction is um
requiem for a dream it's really
disturbing
um but it portrays addiction very very
well um but there's just so many you
know there's so many good films i might
have to
yeah it's too difficult but getting back
to your earlier point the better ones
would get you inside their head yeah so
that you can completely empathize a
beautiful mind stands out to me because
you really i i always you know i've
worked with patients with schizophrenia
and i could never understand like how do
they and and that sort of allowed me to
have insight into what it might feel
like to be a intelligent otherwise you
know functioning person but be plagued
by these these delusions and how easily
you can slip into them and so that for
me was really um a moving film okay all
right so let's see slip in a couple fast
ones let's go uh mikhail mikhail
who says hey guys it's mikhail beau from
canada here in shutter island the main
character thinks he's a hero
investigating a case of psychiatric
hospital at the end we figure out he was
the killer and the psychiatrist made up
the
story to set up uh his therapy my
question can you really convince and
hold someone into a
living
happy dream
for their entire
life
from that standpoint of a morning family
would a person that has no
self-awareness
to be put in jail be a fair thing to do
if he's living peacefully in a dream and
will never regret or know his actions
dude you just got super deep
damn
wow i mean well here's the first thing
let's answer the first question would
that be acceptable therapy to put
somebody inside of their own living
dream in other words to massage their
delusion to the point where they are
living that delusion
well i mean i don't think that would be
legal
um i don't think you know what you're
ridding them of their accountability for
their wrongdoings
absolutely i mean there's so many
there's so many levels there i mean this
is the thing if you don't know of
anything else then that whatever you're
living in is is the your reality right
it's the matrix it's the matrix it's the
matrix and and it goes for you know i've
seen this with you know in in
unfortunate cases with
children who have been in like abusive
situations at home and and they think
that that's normal that's all they know
so they're not even that sometimes
aren't as upset about it until they see
what else alternative exists you need a
comparison right so if you were in your
whole life living in a delusional you
know simulated world you would never
know the difference but until it's just
like yeah it's just like living in the
matrix um would that be a suitable i'm a
little confused because i haven't seen
the movie um treatment but you know
that's what they did to i think it was
in minority port report when they jail
people they just like stick you in this
thing and put a thing on your head and i
think then you're just living in a kind
of
virtual reality world or something for
right you're suspended there yeah you're
suspended basically a dream basically
yeah exactly exactly they lock you like
injury but what i love in terms of
therapy one of the films also that i
love is inception because they're in
their dream it's actually how things
work they go back deep into the
unconscious and they plant a seed and
that seed then germinates and changes
ultimately the characters behavior that
they're trying to you know change and so
the idea of actually getting into
someone's unconscious and planting a
little a little bit of information a
little seed
a life-changing decision that's better
for them or different later on yeah yeah
and that that's what their a lot of
therapy is you just sort of say oh yeah
have you ever thought about it this way
and then you just let them create their
own and then change their behavior on
their own
one more question okay i'll be fast
gotta be fast fast and this is a great
one this is lydia and she says hello to
all my friends naomi who is doing her
masters in neuroscientists on
neuroscience is wondering if movies
could be a very good treatment for
depressed people also if movies could
give a good amount of dopamine just like
getting rewards
uh
my kind regards lydia
and we answer back dearest lydia no okay
my dearest lydia
thank you for your letter um i i i think
yes so so humor is really something that
does release dopamine in the brain chuck
doesn't know anything about humor
let me tell you
give trucks from school school at
let school tell you a little bit about
humor chuck um it no it releases
dopamine in the brain and and and it can
be a very um useful you know first of
all it's a useful defense mechanism
sometimes when people are in pain they
use humor um to deflect but but it's one
of the positive defense mechanisms so um
but but getting in
losing yourself into another person's
story is a good way it's a form of like
healthy dissociation in a way so if
you're ruminating over your problems you
just can't get out of your own head if
you can get engrossed in a film that's
maybe with you know a positive theme and
um something you know that's happy or
funny it can actually help change your
brain in a way and not you know if
you're in a very deep deep depression
it's a neurochemical imbalance maybe not
so much but if you're just feeling a
little bit down you know if you and i'm
sure we've all had that experience of
you watch something that moves you and
it shifts it shifts how you're feeling
yeah but okay but heather if i'm
depressed do i benefit from seeing
people who are more depressed than i am
and i say i guess i don't have it that
bad yeah or do i go
or do i see people who are happy and
then i aspire to that i mean it seems
like you can argue it both ways right
it's a very good question i mean studies
show so there's there's this thing it's
called upward comparison and downward
comparison and so they find that people
are happier in general when they compare
down so they say uh you know look at
people who are worse off than them right
and then they feel better about so if
you're if you're having a problem in
your life right now you say but wait
look at those people in the ukraine
right now like they're really suffering
so put your problems in perspective
you'll feel a little bit better about
your life but if you're comparing
yourself to i don't know richard branson
or somebody who has their own island and
yacht and you know you might feel a
little bit bad about your current
position in life so but not just
patients which makes him the saddest man
in the world
because even though he's worth more
money than anybody you look at him and
go i don't want to be that hey
no no
but his ex-wife on the other hand
he's someone
i'd like to be um but so black black
people have a famously low suicide rate
relative to white people and red fox
once remarked about that he said it's
hard to kill yourself jumping out of the
basement window
that is hilarious guys we gotta we gotta
land this plane uh heather thanks for
giving us some insights here it's all
valuable and this is an unending subject
we're gonna have to do this again yes
because i'm sure i'm sure we didn't get
through all the questions chuck so
we will have to do this again it'll have
to be um your brain on movies the sequel
has happened nicely done sir you see how
i played this i like what you did
all right chuck nice co-host to heather
berlin our favorite neuroscientist neil
degrasse tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]